yeah I guess it depends on the sport my
position fortunately allows me to play a
little bit longer most guys that I've
watched in this league or have seen
retire played in their mid-30s I don't
know how much longer I want to play I
want to make sure I play to a point
where I feel like I'm still contributing
and can help the team and in my position
I can just yell at the younger guys to
to do my job for me and I kind of sweep
behind them so it just kind of depends
on the formation how I'm feeling
physically and mentally as well I think
that's you still want to be excited
about what you're doing but I'm very
passionate about the next phase of
things there is a part of me that's very
excited that my kids will never know I
played and they're just going to know me
as whatever I do next and that excites
me and fascinates me and on some level
that they'll never see me like in the
paper or on TV or doing any kind of
stuff in regards to playing it always
it'll be something different and so I
find that quite humorous actually that
they'll never know their dad and that
that fashion used to take me like a day
to recover from a game and now takes me
like three and so in just in different
ways the nagging injuries that used to
last a couple days now last two weeks
you know so there's stuff like that but
I've done a lot of like my time kind of
stuff with whether it be yoga or pilates
and really tried to be open-minded about
that stuff to help me on the field and
and I think it's helped me out quite a
bit guys used to make fun of me when I
snood yoga and Pilates and and now
they're like well can I sign up for a
class because they see that that I'm
healthy I don't get strains very often I
don't cramp up you know I'm running
faster and harder than they are in a
consistent basis I always have more
energy and so I think that I've kind of
keyed into something and I think the
league in general and players in general
are kind starting to be
a little more open-minded and evolving
to where they need to be I don't know
that's I don't really know when that's
going to be I don't know that exact
moment i think it's just kind of I
really from what I've gathered when I've
talked to other players that have
retired it's kind of like just I don't
want to do this anymore like you just
kind of had it with with the process and
from their perspective the league was
still trying to figure it out and
there's a lot of behind-the-scenes a
turmoil that you know I could see why
that would just kind of great on their
nerves and just be like you know I've
had it you know but I feel like our
league is is growing up so much
especially in the last couple years and
we're starting to become more and more
professional as a league players
starting to become are treated with more
professionalism that it makes me excited
to go to work every day and so I don't I
don't know when that's going to be I
don't know when that switch is going to
be but we can come back here and talk
about it when I figure that out
you